[Music]
let's turn our attention to Tom Cruise
and we have an exclusive for you only we
were one-on-one with Tom as he received
the prestigious Will Rogers pioneer of
the Year award yeah it all happened
during CinemaCon in Las Vegas which is
fitting because Tom rolls the dice with
his life every time he makes an action
movie and Carly still began with his new
mission impossible it's ironic that you
do all these death-defying stunts
and the one that like got you was this
seemingly innocuous jump across the room
[Music]
what's going through your minds when
that happened talk about that pissed
I was really are your foot I myself I
just stuck my foot out just literally
just a split second too long I knew
instance it is broken
did they ever go through your mind like
I may not run again yeah I mean it it
was I was nervous about it I was
definitely what but I really tried to
work hard I worked 10 hours a day on
rehab 7 days a week on helicopter yes
you're up there you're alone you're
spiraling in a ravine I mean what goes
through your mind when you're doing that
don't die please don't make a mistake
don't make a mistake I'm gonna look down
and I'll take it over the waterfalls and
I'm also thinking of I'm acting and it
also as we're going through it so you're
seeing I'm performing but underneath
it's it's a very technical move it's a
very risky move Mission Impossible fall
out hit theatres July the 27th and
there's a major milestone for a cruise
classic it's 35 years of risky business
which is incredible is there anything
specific you can share about that swipe
theme
other slide sing yeah yeah I look I
remember like it was really yesterday we
started playing with it and I just you
know took my pants off and then was slid
across and the earlier ones I slid from
one end to the next cuz the floor was so
polished so I did that a few times I
tried to stop in the middle then I
called the prop guy over set dresser so
look give me give me some you know spray
and I sprayed the floor so that I would
slide and then I would stop it got
sticky right in the center frame so
that's that's how we got the opening
frame